we had I love yous I am in love with you
we thank you and we had a full Disney
movie moments this is your bachelor in
paradise episode 12 recap grab your
glasses it's time for roses and rose
say hello everyone i'm lauren zima
and I'm emotionally exhausted oh you
guys what an episode I mean this is the
penultimate episode of bachelor in
paradise
and so we saw couples come together we
saw couples fall apart
we saw couples meet each other in hotel
rooms for no real reason let's get to it
I remembered that I had just for
Paradise purchased these like fun
tropical glasses and I was using them in
the beginning of the season and I forgot
about them so they're back right on time
about as on time as Whitney was do you
know what I mean okay what did you think
of this episode it was one that really
indicated to us whether certain couples
would leave paradise together would
things last forever
okay not forever it's not determining
that but maybe if they're engaged or
just like still dating okay there's like
a sashimi like I feel like I'm like
putting in a lot of like a ferret right
off the bat we were triggered yes
because we thought that Demi and
Christian had handled things on Monday
night's episode but no they are not done
with their issues and their issues
include Christian being triggered by
things Demi is saying Oh drink every
time someone's triggered on I guess the
chairs
and drink for every just horribly
painful look on demion Christians faces
they were sitting on this bed trying to
talk things out but they weren't even
looking at each other you can't face
your issues if you can't even face each
other
I want drinking for that this ice is
very loud and this plastic cup though
and this episode was very like back and
forth it was like sad couple happy
couple sad couple happy couple yeah I
think maybe the editors didn't want us
to get too burnt out on darkness so they
brought us to the light Hannah takes
someone who feels like home we're going
into the sunshine with Hannah and Dylan
they're gonna get a date card and clay
says that he has never seen two people
spend more time together in their lives
I've never seen two people spend more
time together in my life so it's the
first couple will ask this question
about what do you guys think will Hannah
and Dylan get engaged okay
their date though is to a child's
birthday party I'm gonna call that a
cheap date but you know this is a
bachelor trope we've got to get people
with the children so that the
significant other can see Oh does that
person gonna be a good parent oh oh they
met this strange child today and played
with that child for an hour oh my god
gonna be a great day
I mean I can hang with a child for an
hour 10 minutes 30 seconds okay I did
not expect to be invited to a kid's
birthday party so they're at this
strange child's birthday party
and Ana gives us such a deep observation
she says and I quote I love birthdays I
love birthday police cosplay Anya who
does it
now this surprised me though I don't
know why I guess just because they've
been so strong for so long I thought
that Dylan and Hannah had already
dropped the elbow but they had not so
Dylan tells Hannah he's in love with her
you know I am alone with you and Hannah
told Dylan she loves him too
and of course birthdays release
California and from the blow to the oh
no we still have lonely Connor on the
beach everybody you know I don't want to
shock anyone but things don't seem to
have worked out with Revie on Revie on
about the wedding and that whitney
houston's were a few seasons ago but we
learned something new with connor to
drink every time we learned something
new apparently at crits and crystals
wedding
Connor was kind of vibing with one
Whitney four rounds away a beautiful
brunette but Kalyan came in and grabbed
at Connor and so Connor and Whitney
could not fully explore their
conversation but no she has not left his
mind but everyone else has left Connor
he he is so lonely man and so he just
decides he's got to leave paradise like
what else was here
Whitney's not should I Whitney so I got
a call the producers out a little bit
here I have loved this season everything
about it has been drama and humor and
fabulous editing fun but Connor is gonna
leave just as Whitney Franz Wei who
apparently has been holed up in a hotel
room in Mexico since the wedding shows
up
come on and everyone's like oh my god
this is crazy
Whitney Connor just left I'm gonna just
left that I think you should know about
you wanted to talk to you because he was
super interested in meeting you and you
wanted to talk to him I mean your cars
the cars could have passed each other
[Music]
you guys the producers know Connors into
Whitney and they know Whitney's into
Connor they could have just brought them
together I'm happy to be here finally I
guess here is that you know when they do
the show they promise the hotel Vedanta
I would imagine a certain amount of
appearances and I think they needed more
to happen at the hotel I think I'm gonna
just leave and go after him Whitney gets
to paradise and she turns right back
around and heads to Connor in his hotel
room where by the way he answered the
door shirtless as Whitney said she hoped
she would see this show the gift that
keeps on giving and the paid integration
sponsorship that keeps on living room is
so big wonderful again I'm just
speculating but that would be my guess
hmm but from a beautiful new
relationship blooming to a relationship
that's been around and could be dooming
itself Nicole and clay everybody do you
think you're falling a little bit
and on nakulan clays date it seems quite
evident that clay is not as into Nicole
as she is into him am i right what did
you guys think of what clay had to say
to Nicole another thing I guess I missed
I didn't realise clay hadn't even told
Nicole he was falling for her yet do you
think you're falling a little bit
mm she basically says she's falling in
love with him and he tells her you're my
best friend to me best friend on the
beach in the beach
not even his best friend but
specifically his best friend on this
beach in this contained geographical
area in a specific set amount of time in
which we will spend together honey
produced television show Wow
what do you think it claimed Nicole's
chances as I by doing
welcome to the rose ceremony night so we
are heading to the rose ceremony but
Chris Harrison comes in and cancels the
cocktail party I'm canceling the
cocktail party no wait no drinks but the
people they need to have their cocktail
brew but also I couldn't watch these
people talk through things anymore I
felt I'd seen it all
tonight's rose it's probably the most
meaningful because paradise is almost
over so it's the rose ceremony and oh my
god a quick break for savage Haley I
forgot Haley was here but we saw her
long enough for her to say that Luke s
is a poor man's Nick Viall
Oh God oops not really my type he's the
poor man's me Pete any more alcohol for
that that sounds a little rough didn't
it Nick vials
way hotter than him not necessary I mean
he's not a bad person I don't I'm a
Knick files literally nothing to do with
each other I don't know what I would
anyway
but speaking of pour pour pour pour
Luke s at this rose ceremony
you guys have we ever seen anything like
it
the answer is literally in historically
no Luke decides to give breathe his rose
so she walks up and she says um I know
honestly I came here to find love and a
relationship and
knowing what this Rose represents I
usually I can't say
she rejected the rose I was watching and
thinking has this ever happened before
and then Chris Harrison came in and said
you think never happened before or it's
so awkward so painful so horrible Sora
fiying so deeply troubling did you feel
bad for Lucas let me know in the
comments below
I mean then things got worse Chris
Harrison turned to the group and have
said does anyone want Lucas's Rose is
there anyone else who would like Luke's
rose tonight and drink every time he
said anyone anyone anyone anyone Bueller
Bueller does Ferris Bueller why Lucas's
Rose guess it's pretty serious thank you
so much unfortunately if you're not in a
relationship
say goodbyes it's even painful when he
tries to hug the guys goodbye I think he
walked over to John Paul Jones and JBJ
was confused and Luke had to say
dude I'm hugging you could bah say bye
I'm fine actually very dark to Luke's
credit he handled it well
from from lies of Luke p2a know from
bri-bri
I guess breeze into McDonald the Playboy
of paradise she takes his rose and the
roses are handed out and Haley is
leaving and Sydney is leaving and the
ravine is leaving but you know it's not
gone Chris Harrison drink for every time
you saw Chris Harris in this episode
good evening volatile week I'll drink
again to that mm-hmm
looking good I like the note I like what
can I say
summary what do you his name a collared
shirt with no time arrived with another
beachy bombshell
he says paradise is over but now I'm
here to tell you that that's where
paradise as you know it is over it's not
over this next step is the serious part
of paradise but he was just saying you
guys gotta figure your ish out are you
in or are you out on your significant
other and I need you to be brutally
honest with yourselves and with each
other I love the rest of the episode
from this point because it felt a little
flow and then things go we are getting
yeses that we are getting notes each
couple is making a decision choosing
3-over City I am really excited about
Bri and I'm excited about our future
first up Matt and Bri they're done
honestly
you made the wrong decision
she says she doesn't even know why he
gave her the rose my heart's pounding
chase and Angela they're done he said
something was missing something not just
missing for me and then from the
darkness to the light Dylan and Hanna
yeah they're fine they're definitely
their very own fantasy suites of course
flower petals diving rings falling from
the sky sprite then back to the depths
Nicole and clay she says she's in love
with him
very something hugs her and says if we
do this we do this it's gonna be us be
good you know what does that mean clay I
didn't know but they're ago they're ago
into the fantasy suites did you guys
think they should have gone or should
they have been done let me know in the
comments below
JBJ and tasia next everybody oh he says
he's in love with her but she is not
quite Lou and she says she has to end
things
and JPJ just as they do thank you for
some of them
most magical moments
oh you guys and this is when this moment
turned into a movie I felt like I was
watching a Disney Princess of Prince
right I mean a lot of people have
likened John Paul Jones to John Smith
from Pocahontas and I see it and as much
as I've had some issues with JPJ this
season my cold-hearted heartstrings were
tugged upon they broke up we were crying
and I didn't know what to think first
Taoiseach ran after him on the beach
and her tears were so real and everyone
was crude but it wasn't a reconciliation
it was just I'm so
[Music]
but JPJ remained a prince he picked Asia
up and carried her along the sand just a
few steps he did stop at the stairs but
still he set her down
and they knew it was done
I think in this movie I'm the witch now
cast a spell to make you love him
so some confusion there but they are
over what did you think should I have
stayed with JPJ let me know the comments
below
oh but from the below try to pick
yourself up to the shallows because in
the shallows we are waiting through the
water and things are good Demi and
Christian are gray go to the fantasy
sway it's wonderful they're very in love
and then it's back again to the problems
Chris and Katie I don't know what Chris
is going to say
little bit nervous it's just we've been
going through ups and downs with the
various couples during this episode of
bachelor in paradise from coupled a
couple of things have gone either
sideways or the right way but Chris and
Katie are a problem pair in themselves I
never know what to think with them what
will they do next well the answer is
from moment to moment it's something
different Chris brings Katie over to a
daybed with tears in his eyes quite
clearly to break up with her right and
he's crying and she's crying and he's
like I'm unsure I'm sure
she's like I don't want this I don't
want this this meeting a breakup but
then Katie kind of like talks about what
happened here this shouldn't be this
hard everybody Chris goes from appearing
to end things to saying let's give it a
shot that's not the ringing endorsement
you want from someone Katie
walk away Chris has stuff to figure out
about himself you probably do too you
guys are not ready for this commitment
it should not be this difficult this
early on just saying but from early on
do we are done next week is the finale
everybody paradise is over it's the
moment of truth
ain't Aneta this is real who will
propose who will say knows who will not
leave paradise together tell me your
predictions in the comments I love you
guys so much thank you for watching the
season of bachelor in paradise with me
one more big episode of roses and rose
they left and as we wind things down you
know who we haven't seen in a minute the
has been wonderful JC JC can you come in
please
Oh
jaesi working the collared shirt a note
I look I love it
you've been watching all season long I
just want you to name the couples who
you think have the highest chance of
success of still being together after
all this done Hannah oh speaking of the
dark side
all right everybody I'm on the app cameo
if you want a personal message from me
also please follow me on Instagram I
love seeing your comments and what you
think of things and see you for the
finale
remember paradise is not air on Monday
September 16th
that's the premiere of Dancing with the
Stars starring Bachelorette Hannah brown
check it out
the finale is Tuesday September 17th on
ABC bye it was written like that I said
that
[Music]